okay what up guys
um we just had our 100th episode and we
had we had Andrew Tate on it's we
recorded it it hasn't it's not uploaded
yet but we had some of the guests from
the panel um we have a special guest
Brittany Renner
um and we're just having a light
conversation after and we have a lot of
these conversations after shows where
even where it's like super heated we'll
sit down and like chat and you guys
don't really get to see it so I decided
to do a quick live and just show you
guys what happens after show so we were
just talking about
um about your experience on the show
yeah a little Miss hate video yeah
yeah whatever
yeah no um but I should write you a
check for all the money I made off the
video
my question to you was what part of the
hate comments resonated with you to
where you were like okay why does this
hurt me I think it hurt me because I
love men
and obviously what those men were taking
from the episode was that I don't like
men and misandrist and they were saying
oh this is where she'll be single
forever and I'm like I
have men you know and I love them so
he's like why are you coming from me in
that way like making me feel like I'm I
have no value just because I'm I'm
talking about my opinions and stuff so I
think that's what really got me because
I don't want to be seen like I'm
anti-men do you know what I mean that's
not what I'm about like I'm just about
um women having their rights women
having their autonomy that's it but men
do your thing your kings we love you you
know that's kind of what I want to be
known for and I think I didn't like that
I was seen in that lie and it made me
think is it the stuff I said are they
misconstruing what I said do you know
what I mean right it's definitely what
you said and how you said it yeah what
do you think I said that and I'll tell
you why because I watched the interview
as well and I'll compare myself to you
because me and you I've listened but you
get hate too though listen all the time
exactly I'm the Troublemaker for a
reason because I come here and
everything no time on one on one of the
episodes is people saying I've had
people approach me in in life in real
life to say to me yo you're basically 13
now and you ain't got a man I need to
take you to my church and they were
actually quite
intentionally hate terrific in my face
but guess what this is the thing I
really don't care because what I believe
is my truth and whatever people are
telling me doesn't stick to me because
their hate towards me is more sometimes
of a reflection of themselves because
they cannot understand how the Nava can
say all these things I still feel good
about herself I don't really care if
somebody's telling me I'm 30 I'm going
to be on my own and I don't have a man
because my truth is that if I want to be
with somebody I can work for it but the
thing about it I reflect on myself a lot
I feel like everyone should and if you
feel like you're doing something wrong
and if a lot of people are saying the
same thing
I have to think wait am I doing the
right thing is what they're saying right
so I think obviously I have
self-confidence in myself yeah but I
also need to reflect and actually think
okay I know what I believe in am I being
delusional you know why would you take
that offense [ __ ] you why would you take
offense to it if someone's like telling
you something you can either if you know
yourself you can be like okay they don't
know what to talk about or you can take
it assess it take what they said
um and then leave the pieces that you're
like yeah no that's not me why would you
get
offended by something because when I
first came on the show they didn't like
me at all and I was just like well I
don't know why they don't like me or I
would listen to what they were saying I
was like okay well maybe I should listen
more take what they say and say and do
things differently or say things
differently and understand from them and
if they're speaking a little rubbish I'm
like okay y'all don't know what you're
talking about go on with your life but I
don't think there you should get
offended first of all is the internet
they everybody gonna say whatever they
want to say you know people always say
it's the Internet it's light we bump the
Internet it's life people are killing
themselves because of the internet like
we need to stop people are killing
themselves outside of the internet you
know
what like when I came on the show it was
so overwhelming like so much like but
why are you coming
you also made the choice like like you
were talking most of the show and
there's people that come on they don't
really know what type of show it is and
they're just they just keep quiet
they're like I can see the shock in
their face in there and they're no I I
know but I'm saying like if you see the
type of environment you don't like it
you can always just opt out and not say
it like I didn't know what I was gonna
leave as soon as like I was like okay
this is that type of but then you're
just walking out it's like you're
walking out of a situation then I look
back because I'm like oh she can't hold
her but then you also but you could have
you could have just been you could have
just been quiet and said okay like what
I've maybe been offended silently and
then just when a camera moved just
walked out like there's girls that have
done that it's not like I don't force
anyone to be here yeah I I'm not gonna
lie I didn't know the type of
environment was I didn't even know I was
coming on the show Eddie I'm gonna call
you out Eddie reached out to me and I
thought I was going on his podcast and
then obviously I was here so I didn't
know this was gonna happen I didn't know
obviously now that I know that's when
when you invited me for this episode I
understood what it's about and it's like
okay don't take anything personal and
obviously I have a podcast when I have
guests come on my on my show I'm very
like I care about how they feel because
I I I'm I'm a massive believer in
protecting people's mental health
because I've seen what people go through
like people want to kill themselves
because of this stuff and I don't want
to contribute towards it and I don't
care if it's an entertainment I do not
[ __ ] care we need to protect people's
mental health and that's how I run my
show and a lot of shows that I've been
on stand-up TV I got a lot of history
how are you wait wait Harry was like
guys please just checking is everyone
okay obviously I didn't get that from
you and it was just a very like well
actually but do you realize do you
realize you no one forced you to say
anything no one forced you to put
yourself out there you were saying the
thing so how is
because Pro didn't reach out to you to
see if you were okay because everything
happened no no no no no no no I know
you're not a bit toxic but you you were
saying things like Pearl said if you if
you didn't want people to come after you
you could have just set back but you
kept my followers I didn't know no no it
doesn't it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter if you don't know the followers
it's life people are gonna come at you
no matter what internet off the internet
so if you don't want people coming at
you it's just like okay sit back not say
anything it's just it's just an
accountability thing like I just feel
like like when Andrew was talking about
how everything in life is your fault I
literally believed that yeah because
it's like like you know when that when
that girl came on and she like got a
couple points on me and honestly like I
felt like she was just arguing like I
just felt she came in like he did right
and like ready to say all this stuff and
I just wasn't prepared but like instead
of saying oh like she click baited me
she did this this and this I'll be like
you know what I wasn't prepared I'll
take my owl I'll let her get her Tick
Tock Cloud off of it but it's it's like
take accountability is I should have
asked more questions daddy so when Eddie
was like oh you want to come on a
YouTube channel and that's literally
what he said a YouTube channel about
relationships I should have asked which
YouTube channel is because he's a
podcast that he has a podcast I just
assume sister what was stopping you when
you got here
um
that was a show okay okay but like what
was stopping when you got here and you
realized it wasn't the his podcast from
like Googling the podcast you were on I
didn't Google it because we're already
here but it started I know I know but
I'm saying I'm saying you could you
usually get like a half hour before the
show starts people like will chill out
hang out whatever so you could look up
the podcast you could see the titles
within five minutes of research and I've
had people do that and leave yeah yeah
you live and you learn and this is why I
will never accept any invitation to any
show any podcast until I know exactly
what I'm walking really
I'm sorry no but
it's an opportunity that's the truth
every single time especially for when it
comes to the internet you know one thing
there'll be people that like it there'll
be people that don't like it especially
if you don't have an opinion that is
strong whatever that opinion is be ready
to face the backlash when because I met
you through Castillo when I went on his
show I knew that there's a possibility
that people go against me because I come
with a different personality and I'm
always ready the moment the camera is on
I know the consequences of my actions so
there is no excuse to go somewhere and
be like the camera is on and now your
haters that your followers are haters
and now you are this and you of that you
go on that you be ready for anything
it's Showbiz I don't know how it is I
have to keep bringing it back you're
Sagittarius
no I'll tell you the difference Pisces
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter what
division
no I mean no I didn't feel attacked I
felt like because Pearl is not in my
situation I feel like it's easy to be
like oh well you know you made a mistake
because let's go back to what she said
during the podcast which was we were
talking about the the kids stuff she's
like well you made a a poor choice these
are the repercussions I can see how you
feel that way but like let me try to
break it down for you so you can
understand so I I get it it's like if
you're not it's it's all fun and games
until it's you so that's where for me
like it's it's not even like oh she's
coming for me I'm just trying to explain
to her this is my perspective it takes
two to tango don't put all that on me
you know what I mean because it at the
end of the day I open my legs and I can
have a baby or not but I can't have a
baby without semen you know so yeah I
didn't I didn't feel like I I feel like
Pearl's inner like her her style too
like I've told her
um before I actually like really like
the past few days did like a deep dive
watching all of you guys like really
getting into it like I felt like there
there was this unlike likable quality to
her because she wasn't she was not going
to say her personal experience but she's
gonna ask a question that you're like
girl you're a woman why are you trying
to go against us but like I feel like it
still poses for good conversation and
when I watched her wife school when I
really like was talking to her outside
of it I'm like I could see her
personality so I feel like understanding
her personality and then when it comes
time in here to interview it is you're
going to get a little bit of a different
person because you did a research
but it's also your responsible to do
your due diligence let me tell you
again 30 minutes 30 minutes it doesn't
take long to research me it's the same
boat
no because you've talked a lot let me
stop it for two seconds because this is
the truth what I don't like and what I
will not stand for is somebody that
actually had the exact same experience
as me be upset because you could not
handle it with the substance of the
woman that you are Pearl and anybody on
this on this podcast what they did to
you that night is they won you lost
every time no it is it is
no no you're cutting me off and this is
the problem that they had with you then
because you're not willing to listen to
where you went wrong you went wrong
because you were not strong enough in
your opinion I've come here I've got way
more hate than you way more hate than
you all the super chats every single
comment on there is about the Navajo
delusional she'll end up on hone I'm
older than you so on top of that I'm
even more of a Target I'm single too so
I've had that sort of attitude in fact
on that same day that I came Sarah came
for me a man came for me and he told me
a lot of things and I held my own why
because as a woman I stand on my own two
feet I believe my truth and they know
thing that nobody can tell me one or two
that can make me change my mind because
I know who I am if you're coming on the
internet and you're going to put your
voice out there be sure that you know
who you are because people come to you
and if you doubt yourself that's why it
goes wrong your problem is that you are
weird to come here no it was it's about
I'm not I'm not here to argue it was a
podcast I I thought we were all just
talking about how our opinions I didn't
know it was gonna what if someone
doesn't agree with your opinion
right you're not agreeing with me it's
okay but it's when you're saying my
faith is weak okay so hold on hold on
hold on hold on I wanna I wanna go to
that hold on let us I want to go to that
choose there because
it if you look at it because I was
sitting there and you were talking if
you look at it and you listen to what
you're saying and how you say you
believe this way you went one place and
you changed your whole belief system
it's like how can you be this and then
go somewhere instantly change it because
of you saying that sitting in this seat
right here
it gave other people a perspective that
you weren't strong enough in your faith
to go to another place to where it was a
different environment different Religion
different everything to be able to stay
strong in that as soon as you got there
or not as soon as you got there but when
you got there it changed it flipped so
from what you from the words that came
out of your mouth it gave other people a
perspective and that's what they were
saying to you it wasn't that they were
saying anything we're on a podcast with
lots of people talking you guys didn't
even let me finish you didn't let me no
we didn't let you we did let you finish
yes we did we did let you finish because
that's how it started where I started to
it wasn't because I went to China it was
because I just started reflecting on
life so I'm not saying I I literally
just went to China and my face just but
that's what you said
okay but the whole but even even if it
even if okay let's say it how okay okay
okay even if even if even if it happened
over even something else but even this
what you're doing okay now it's
emotional response to something they can
just say do you know what I did get
emotional but I [ __ ] up [ __ ] you the
haters I'm a G I'll still stick by what
I stand my faith is not weak I went to
China I just saw a different perspective
and I re-analyzed bam situation finito
like I don't really benefit from it you
know what I mean you do to me it's not
really something I want to talk about
but you've been you don't benefit from
reacting like this and putting something
else if you didn't want to talk about it
you went on another podcast and talked
about it it's like about it because when
are we walking when we went on Eddie's
show do you know Eddie orchestrated the
whole thing right so we went on the show
we were meant to talk about
um I can't even remember women he said
Soraya wanted to talk about it was that
not true no that's a lie so Sarai was
talking about experience and then Eddie
was like this is good content let's film
and he just started filming so obviously
obviously I'll say it in my chest you
don't have to feel like you were rude
and I said it on the show but that's
just is what it is I I'm ready to move
on from it because it is just what it is
I don't personally I don't agree with
that way of conducting I don't care
about thick skin we don't need to be
thick skin I'm sorry we do have I'm
sorry we need to have censorship Because
unless people know what they're going
into we know my sister if we had
censorship then who's the one that's
going to control that because if we have
censorship according to pulse followers
I should be shut down immediately do not
what I'm trying to say is not everyone
is you and exactly
the whole point is if you ain't like me
don't go and talk like you like me don't
go sit against somebody like pumpkin
this is why you'll put on it and I'm not
gonna move on
because you are the problem with modern
women and I'll tell you why because no I
am not because I stand here and people
come for me and that's the strongest
you're cutting me off
if you don't interrupt me then I'll tell
you very very well done to you because
I'll tell you something when you come on
the internet wherever you go you think
you got a voice you stand by it you
don't take it back and get upset because
somebody didn't agree with you I've had
way more hate than you I've had a lot
more rejection and a lot more reactions
against me than you have had and I've
stood here and the reason why it didn't
stick to me is because I am not weak I
stand in my thoughts I stand in my
beliefs I understand in my truth if you
are not a woman that can speak in her
truth do not put yourself against people
that go against you so many times
okay
because you're talking [ __ ] now you're
talking [ __ ] no because
no it's about it's about the fact
everybody cares about how some people
want stuff
you are the Exotic design about yourself
it's not about me
bro you went against somebody like Pearl
and this is about Pearl I won't even
make it about my about myself well okay
for me the same way in fact I argue with
Paul way more than you do I've been on
the show way more times than you have I
faced Auntie Jenny way more times than I
than you have
wait wait wait wait wait shut up and
listen
wow
it's so close no but she's not she's not
saying that she's doing it for class
she's she's giving an example that she's
been in your shoes but she's handled it
a different way she's taking it
you've not let me finish because you say
you want to move on if you want to move
on let me finish speaking because I'm
most other than you and I'll not stop
until I finish my point and my point
simply is if you are not willing to take
[ __ ] don't go and talk if you're not
willing to stand your ground as a woman
don't go out there and be going for a
fight if you're not ready to fight you
exit the situation straight away if you
want to stay in Fight You Stand Tall and
you fight I'm not afraid to sit here and
argue with this
listen you're still cutting me off
listen you had a conversation that
didn't go your way you didn't like what
you heard and now you're labeling people
to be misogynistic racist and this and
that when I've had the same experience
on the podcast you did I've had the same
experience I've had bigger head to head
with both people that you're referring
to and I don't feel the same way because
I understand it's not personal it's not
about race it's about who are you what
do you stand for how much do you respect
yourself and what you think and what you
believe and clearly but how you have
acting even how you're acting right now
it's not very high because Dick writing
I don't need to dig right
because because at the end of the day
you asked about my experience right if
we're going to talk about dinner I
didn't ask about your experience don't
don't bring it about your experience
about mice okay fine my experiences
let's make it denial and forget about
Esther let me tell you yeah a powerful
strong woman that respects itself and
holds the truth will sit here and have
people shouting in her ear telling her
that she was not abused for five years
because she didn't report it to the
police and guess what she does she says
that with conversion says you say what
you got to say I know my truth and by
the way my sisters if you need help I'm
here for you it's that simple I don't
care about what these people have to say
because in my opinion they talk [ __ ]
because that truth is not my truth
simple simple nothing more nothing less
and instead you choose to see here shout
and be written to the points wait wait
do the point to the point that you're
swearing at me no no I didn't yes you
did I didn't you're like oh that [ __ ] no
no no no no I did that it actually I
didn't answer wait wait wait wait wait
wait stop because you're fighting
against the person that stands on your
side listen be quiet for a few seconds
you're still shouting
you are the problem with the other women
it's so embarrassing to see here and
here a sister like you speak to a woman
like me in the way that you have spoken
to me it's embarrassing it's
embarrassing people are sitting here
trying to give you pointers so that you
can survive
shut up for two seconds why are you
doing so much listen be quiet you're
probably be quiet be quiet Esther be
quiet because you need to learn
better than you actually it's not about
Cloud chases yes you are Esther stop for
three seconds because
foreign
I'll give you 30 more seconds can you
finish your point in 30 seconds okay and
then I'll give you 30 seconds to respond
and then we'll be done okay my Point
simply is ladies if you're going to open
your mouth be ready for the consequences
that will come after your words if
you're going somewhere and people are
coming for you and you cannot handle
that and you can feel upset it's because
you are not comfortable with who you are
don't blame it on other people it's
really that simple don't come here call
Pearl names if you are not the G that
can actually sit there and debate
intellectually without any issues that's
that simple emotional response is
weakness there you go it's okay okay
Esther you have 30 seconds what I have
to say is when I was invited on the show
I didn't know I was coming on Pearl show
Eddie invited me onto a YouTube show I
take accountability because I should
have asked and made sure I clarified
which show I was getting going on I
didn't know I've never seen this type of
show before I would have not opted in I
I wouldn't I don't like aggressive going
back insulting each other I don't that's
I'm a presenter you know it's not good
for my brand I don't I don't do that
type of stuff so it's like when I came
here I was just like wait we're going
against trans people like at times
okay okay okay okay
30 seconds time's up your time's up just
saying okay let's let's talk about
something else uh what was the other
thing we were talking about oh we're
talking about body oh go ahead Britney
because I'll give you two minutes no I'm
good I feel like it would just be
probably um for the viewers and
everybody out there I feel like it would
be interesting to hear everyone's
perspective on how they feel about the
100th episode and sitting with Andrew
Tate and like like really kind of seeing
how his energy is in person because a
lot of people are most likely never
going to meet him yeah so I feel like we
all got a chance to kind of yeah that's
a good good idea Brittany you know so
Brittany why don't you faster I felt
like he was he was really polite in
person I didn't expect him to be like
you said so smiley
um very warm and I will say that I do
feel like he is very is very pretty
grounded he is fair
um there are just things obviously I
just don't agree with about the being
agreeable to the point of where it's not
your own identity but I also understood
where he was coming from
um I understood the perspective I don't
agree but no I felt like he was like so
different in person and I feel like
that's why you can't really judge people
based on that he was just different I
don't know am I am I tripping did you
guys feel that way no no why don't you
45 seconds yeah
I actually I liked him a lot I remember
when he got canceled I said the only
problem with this guy is the fact that
he's exposing certain truths and not
providing a solution to those who are
suffering from it that's it other than
that listen here he's better looking in
person
yes I I I try to hate on him he's bad
looking person he's smiling his friend
he's got high energy he's a good
Sagittarius sunshine in human form he's
actually quite cool I liked him yes
yeah I feel like he was a straight
talker and you know what I I really rate
the way he speaks he really knows how to
speak like it will add context and then
he'll make his point I think it takes a
lot of talent to do that and you can
tell he's been doing it for a long time
so I have to respect that in him
obviously I didn't agree completely with
a lot of stuff you were saying because I
I feel like he was a bit one-sided when
I was talking about what men wants and
he wasn't really talking about how to
make women happy but I I I appreciated
that he was also giving us a perspective
of a lot of men out there so I did
appreciate that but I I just wish we
could like explore more about what women
want really
I just think that Society I was always
talking about what women want is that
the timer I just feel like society's
always talking about women what women
want and whenever whenever we talk about
what men might want like we always need
to have a response and it's like why
can't we just let the men talk for a
second because like we we there's Steve
Harvey like talks about what women want
all the time there's a million different
shows
um as for Andrew Tate
I was actually so nervous I don't know
why like I was a ciao what I was too
old
I think I was I kind of think I was a
little quieter because I was like I'm
just like nervous I don't know why but
he was so nice
um it was really nice if a lot of people
don't know we were supposed to go to all
of us we're supposed to go to Dubai my
passport expires within six months so we
couldn't actually like get in I couldn't
get in the country
um so he actually came to us which I
thought was really like kind of him to
come yeah like fly all the way here but
yeah he was really nice
um I was really nervous but overall I
already liked him before I didn't like
him the first time I saw him if you see
my very first reaction to him I was
actually mean because he had a cheating
party
and I was like what is this cheating
party and I was like he would invite all
his girlfriends over at the same time
where like all the girls he would cheat
with and like they would just go to the
same place and it was kind of funny but
I was like what why would you do that
but I didn't understand what but now
that I understand his world view a
little bit more I was like oh well
that's why yeah he was very I from White
the stuff he was saying like beforehand
from uh watching Kevin Samuels uh with
pearl it it opened up
um my view on like actually listening to
people or listening to what these men
are saying instead of just taking a
cliff and taking for how these people
are clipping it and wanting to get their
agenda across but actually I listened to
him and I like sat down and like
actually listened to some of the stuff
that he said beforehand so I was like he
the what he is saying
is not crazy it's the way he's saying it
and people a lot I'll say people and a
lot of women don't like the way that he
is saying it because it's very like raw
like this is it this is how I'm gonna
say and I don't care if you don't like
the way I'm saying it I'ma say it this
way and I feel like a lot of people
don't like it like that but it's like if
you get past what he's like how he's
saying it and listen to actually what he
is saying is like oh okay it's not as
outrageous as
people make it out to be yeah that's why
I actually purposely didn't really go
and look at his content because I was
like I want to see
who he actually is and what his energy
is actually saying because I understand
the same way that people say oh you
created you edited this way to make me
look worse the other day it's the same
way that happens to him and
realistically he was way more balanced
and actually a lot more kind of
calming in his presence than what he
actually seems online I'm not gonna lie
he spoke since there was a lot of
balance in what he said and you know I
know people expecting me to Clash with
him and I didn't he was cool I liked him
it was funny he had to build Phantom
result with his Clementines and stuff I
think the only thing I didn't agree with
was like him talking about a man will
cheat like women are delusional like I
think that's not a good message if they
have the opportunity to they will if
they have like the okay okay I'll give
you an example even a good man would
have a hard time being in Tiger Woods
positions having a position having a Bus
full of models waiting for him that are
trying to [ __ ] him every single day it's
like even a good like my my dad I'll
give you he's top one percent doesn't
cheat but my dad doesn't have social
media and he doesn't have beautiful
models waiting for him every day after
work I think that would be hard for even
a good man yeah to say no to like even
my dad if he was in a position where
beautiful women are trying to do that
every single day that's hard that's
really hard for a guy get approached as
well in fact true true true but it's not
usually it's not usually by men you want
it would I would also argue I would also
argue that it would be hard for a woman
to stay faithful if every day she was
approached by high value men that's true
so but yeah like you've been in that
position it's yeah it's if every day
you're getting messages from like the
top men in society
I I think that's hard for women to turn
down we're hypergamous
so it's not really about the quantity of
men that approach you it's the quality
just morally I think everybody knows
that cheating is wrong you know like Tay
even said it himself when a woman cheats
on a man the pain that he feels so they
know it's wrong innately but they think
that they have that path to do it
because I'm a man I'm a high value man
and it's like do you know that pain that
you felt she feels that it's yeah no I
and I I agree with you I've I've been
cheated on it was really hard but but at
the end of the day it's just not the
same because like at the end of the day
like I could get past it because I was
like you know what it was just a random
it wasn't like he wasn't in love with
her but like the way we would feel if a
man was in love with someone else that's
how men feel about us cheating on them
sexually like there's just uh do you
think it's because there's just like uh
how do I want to say this do you think
it's because men are weaker in that
department to where it's like oh you
can't even I can't believe you had sex
with guys before you even met me because
that's my [ __ ] you know what I mean
like I almost feel like it's because
there's such a gap in where women really
are and where men are emotionally and
mentally I no I just think it's like men
and we can't undo biology right so like
we can't undo the thousands of years of
biology and how how did you pass on your
genes to the Next Generation for women
it was getting the best man that they
possibly could the strongest tallest
biggest highest status because then your
kid would survive that meant he could
protect you he could pass on resources
to you and your kid would be strong and
would be able to protect itself for like
vice versa for men it was I don't want
to pass on resources to a kid that's not
mine so it was I can't have a
promiscuous woman because the kid might
not be mine my jeans might not even get
yeah my genes might not get passed down
so even though like we're in 2022 and we
have like different things that offset
this stuff you can't undo our biology
but I also think it's accountability I
think like
Brittany was saying take you're
literally like the male version of me
and you're praised and I'm shamed I
think it's because we are not holding
these men accountable like you would say
you basically called Britney a hoe
before you met her that is so unfair and
I think if we started to say no Brittany
Not Just Brittany in that situation not
when you are or anything not in that
situation say taste a hoe Britain is a
hoe actually hold each other accountants
and it's just it's just but here's
here's the thing like on the other side
on the other side when you were away
when was the first time you got messaged
by someone with a blue check mark or
like any attention probably when I was
like 20 21. okay 2021 she got the world
at her fingertips like ju just by being
beautiful right she can get messaged
from like the top men in society it's
not the same for man when a man's 20 21
no woman's checking for him maybe maybe
a very select few but even even if
they're very good looking like like
they're not they're not getting [ __ ]
from Rich girls
number one I'm what I'm saying is the
men so we're all getting those women
like actually saying that it's real
because it's not right at the end of the
cheating is wrong men or women biology
or not it's wrong and I think if we
actually start to say you know what this
man has got three baby mamas you're
[ __ ] ridiculous you're playing with
me and here's the thing but the thing is
it's such okay it's such a who who's at
fault when most 80 of women 90 of women
are sexually active but only roughly
five to ten percent of guys can do what
you're saying so it's the women are more
promiscuous than the men it's like the
problem you're talking about is so
minuscule it's so small like maybe 20 of
men can't say women are more promiscuous
women women have more sexual partners
now what are you doing I'm coming for
you today now I'm your Auntie Jenny
trust me you sure at me way too much I
did not accept this respect this is why
men will cheat because somebody's
talking to you and you're still cutting
them off for no reason Pearl please
continue so it doesn't even need to be
high value but do you know what I'm
saying so I'm saying like Okay they're
predicting that 45 of women will be
single and childless that's that so much
so that the big banks are predicting
this these women that are going to be
single and childless and are on the path
to that it's not like they're not
sexually active they're probably
sleeping with someone there's not a
plethora of virgins around that are
women but there is one in three men
under 30 year virgins
so who who's more promiscuous if the
women aren't virgins the body counts are
getting higher the the and where on the
other hand men it's a very small
percentage that can actually get sex and
father a bunch of kids so that's why I
say like I know Tate tries he's he's
like don't make it he said she said but
but just by and large it's more on the
women because one we're in control of
sex we pick who we sleep with and we're
more sexually active than them in a
sense I agree because on average yes
you're right
um women are having sex a lot more
however when we're talking about
promiscuity men have three times more
sexual partners than women so when men
have I think it's like 24 and
um the last time the last time Google it
right now I made sure because I thought
my recent before coming back I was like
okay I need to I need to know so if if
that's true again it goes back to The
Prado principle right so let's say the
average number is higher for for men
typically it's because the top five
twenty percent even we'll even say
thirty percent of men let's give them
30. like they they sleep with 50 60 100
150 girls but one out of three are
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year historically historically exactly
that's why I agree with that but that's
why I'm saying like by and large women
are sleeping with a very small
percentage of men but like how many
percentage are ruining it for the other
men they keep sleeping with so many
women they're ruining it for them okay
so actually it's that part you could
argue that but you could also say it's
more on the women because we're in
control of sex most men like if we went
to a biological level their biology is
to sleep with whoever they can
right by like most men if you get if you
get if you get if you get right but but
for the men right where we have to be
more selective and sacred with who we
give it to right like we we value sex
more like emotionally than men do
they'll just and like most men you get
butt naked in front of them
what they're they're not too and so it's
like you're telling that small
percentage of men like oh don't don't do
that okay fine but at the end of the day
I think it's more on women because
there's more sexually promiscuous women
than there are sexually promiscuous men
and it's men's mating strategy to do
that that's their biology where it's not
an armed biology to be promiscuous but
we're the ones doing it but we have this
like feminism empowerment you can do
whatever you want and still be fat where
it's like I feel like as as women if if
like you should come back and say you
know what wait for someone that loves
you you know wait for so wait for this
wait for that
um that's that's just my opinion on it I
just think it's more on the women
because there's more of us doing it than
the men
yeah kinda I mean I don't promote
promiscuity but I just think that
there's just a double standards where
like men are just seen as it is what it
is it's just biological you should like
sex more but women enjoy sex they do
like it's okay would you know what the
biggest problem I would say is really
really really really and truly is the
fact that all of a sudden from one for
one reason or the other everybody wants
to talk about who they are having sex
with and who they take to bed to the
point that you disclosing your sexual
orientation is something that is even
important at the end of the day
listen you may know that I'm not a
virgin because I like I told you I was
in a relationship for fire you're not
whatever
listen whatever I do or don't do is not
for people to know right it's not for
people to want to discuss it's not for
people unless I'm gonna show you my body
my naked body I don't need to talk to
you about whatever I do in bed with
someone else and yeah I think that's one
of the problems that also people are
having you know they're going a bit like
listen as a woman you can have sex fine
what matters mostly first and foremost
is how you handle yourself how selective
you may be at the end of the day they
look for Purity to a certain extent but
if you're not a virgin don't worry my
sister hide yourself well don't be there
expecting men to accept women to to just
be sexually open and move in certain
ways that are mad and not not get the
repercussion that is why when I dress
myself I am a beautiful woman with a
good body I am and I know and I don't
need anybody else to tell me I got a
mirror but guess what when I walk around
I dress in a certain way why because I
want to display myself in a way that
brings back the attention that I am
looking for so when men approach me they
don't approach me like I'm a hoe when a
man approach me they approach me with
respect every everything comes down to
how you choose to portray yourself a lot
of women want to portray themselves as
hoes and be like yeah I'm that girl hot
go summer what do you think that's going
to do to you what is that going to do to
your other sisters handle yourself with
more care I stand here like I said I
want to be a role model to every single
woman be powerful be strong be
intellectual be educated but don't
forget respect yourself don't be saying
that [ __ ] who I want to [ __ ] no be
selective I agree women definitely need
to be held accountable definitely
because I do think like Tate said we are
the ones creating the problems for each
other because if you're opening your
legs to any man now then they don't even
feel the need to get married anymore
because they're like well I can just get
sex like it's so easy however that what
I'm just trying to say is don't we can't
just put it on the women because these
men are the ones sleeping with them for
50 for 50 years we have put it on the
man okay there's a lot of little things
in society you guys probably don't even
notice and I didn't either before I
started like really listening to what
men say like if you say okay she got
knocked up it sounds like something that
happened to her not a choice she made
who knocked her up he did we always put
the blame on the man it's it's very new
this is a new type of content where you
put any accountability on women watch
watch some early 2000s like Steve Harvey
dating it no watch watch them early
2000s Steve Harvey dating advice where
these women come up to him and like he
just says oh like even even the idea of
oh you intimidate guys no there's
probably something about you that guys
don't like
and and that's just being honest
um sweet feminine girls don't intimidate
anybody there's probably something about
you guys don't like
um and then on top of that it's like
I just think men are never allowed to
have standards like even every time a
man has a standard he's shamed for it so
if they say oh I like thin women I like
pure women they say he's slut-shaming
body shaming it's not the same for for
for women can I just go back to you all
the points about the fact that um we
always put it on men so I don't agree
with that because again I did a lot of
research into this so 90 of single
motherhood it's a woman so in a single
parent home it's a woman that is the
single parent how can you say that we're
always putting it on men when women are
the ones stepping up for their kid so
I'll tell you you're right you're right
90. 90 of women are awarded custody like
I've actually talked to divorce like
lawyers about this they say they love
representing women in court it's much
easier for women than it is for men I'm
not saying it's easy either way like
court is tough but I'm saying but I'm
saying fight for it and I'm saying I'm
saying I I've actually I know some
someone that went through this where he
was trying to get like custody of his
children and it's very hard because once
if he leaves the home then she can not
let him see like not let him see his
kids for say six months so with this guy
it was like she kicked him like like
they were fighting whatever he left so
because because she wanted him out of
the house I'm gonna clarify he wanted to
be a part of his kids lives what
happened was because of covet his court
date kept moving like they kept moving
it back and what happened was she went
to court and said he hasn't been around
for eight months he hasn't been around
for a year and he'd been trying the
whole time and so it's like there's a
lot of situations where men want custody
of their children and they can't get it
and there's even men that kill
themselves because she leaves she takes
half of their his assets and he takes
the kids and he doesn't have access to
their kids like there's a whole it's
like men's right to activists you
probably never heard of them they talk
about these issues where like men there
was a guy in Ohio in the US
he his
um his girlfriend or whatever had a baby
and she gave the kid up for adoption he
wanted the kid he had no rights to his
kid stuff like that happens all the time
but nobody and I don't know and so when
you say when you say 90 like my thing is
like we don't think about why don't they
have access to their children and also
what would you rather let me ask you
because you got a son would you rather
leave your child with a babysitter that
is a woman or babysitter that is a man a
babysitter yeah a baby sits at Nanny
whatever a woman or a man I mean I would
probably prefer a woman exactly exactly
because at the end of the day this
although I understand what you're trying
to get at we can't just put it on women
and everything like that but we also
have to understand we as women we've got
different talents and Gifts okay and I
think that's kind of like what a lot of
men are trying to get at is like you
have a certain Talent which is the power
to attract which means you can get
basically any guy that you want if
you're easy enough okay so I do
understand the red rhetoric of saying be
more selective because you as a woman
got way more power in your hands to
create that interaction than a man would
fine self-control take your power with
responsibility as a woman yes naturally
you will stay with your child because
you're more nurturing that's your
natural gift that still doesn't mean
that a woman is to be excused by it for
everything again for the sake of
argument right here and also because
you've put me in this position where I
actually want to stand against you I
will say men and women both are equally
entitled to complain about what is going
on because both are messing up a lot of
women they are not fit to take care of
their children but because of the
bitterness and anger they have towards
the relationship that didn't work out
they made their child suffer they take
advantage of the fact that they're a
woman and they mark their man that is
not okay there's a there's and like
women let's just be honest like women
are spiteful when they hate a man they
hate and I'm not saying all women I'm
not saying every person does this but
it's like women will use the kids as a
pawn and what happens is a lot of times
even Kanye that happened in front of us
he he his his um another thing they'll
do is they can move States and the
father has no say if they gave the
woman's like primary custody
um and I'm not saying like I know all
the ins and outs of the laws this is
just like from talking to divorce
attorneys and it's like
um it's just like
men their issues are not brought to the
Forefront and it's really sad that like
you know a lot of times a big issue is
men committing suicide after divorce
there is a guy I just learned this the
other day so I'm probably going to
butcher it but our whole most of the
domestic violence laws are based off of
a system that automatically assumes that
the woman's the victim and then the U.S
and so it's like a lot of men like most
when you talk to people that have
actually worked in domestic violence
most domestic violence situations are
mutually abusive where the man and the
woman are hitting each other and and the
men still get put away and the women
don't a woman can just call the cops and
like uh a cop can come will come in and
automatically based on their training
assume that the woman's the victim okay
wait uh again advocate for women that go
through these situations
I don't know what the stats tell you I
don't know what the stats are not
telling you because these things you
cannot actually regulate because a lot
of things go on it's from um can I just
just just to give you perspective it's
from people that work with these couples
and that work at women's shelters will
tell you this so much so much so much so
that they're like there is um the three
feminists that came up with the the
system that the justice and I'm
butchering this but it's like the system
that the justice system is built on that
automatically assumes the woman's the
victim they were saying that even in
their practice it wasn't what they saw
that they were saying you know what it's
actually mutually abusive but sorry go
ahead go ahead well I was just going to
say that when it comes to domestic abuse
I believe that women are inherently more
vulnerable to be in that situation
because when a woman does commit and
this is why men get upset that women
cheat because when a woman commits to a
man she gives herself emotionally when
you attach to yourself to somebody
emotionally now you are a victim to all
of these things whereas men as undertake
very quietly quite rightly said he's got
the decision whether he wants to make
you 10 out of 10 happy or 5 out of 10
happy and keep you crying here and there
because it is true that when Once men
get a woman to fall in love with them
they've got the power that's also what
men don't understand and that's how they
mess about and that's why domestic
violence I believe is so prevalent
amongst women being the victim the
victims instead of being the
perpetrators although there are cases of
course the women do take the piss and
everything but I'm saying people that
like work in these environments are
saying usually it's mutual
so like people that work like with the
couples that try to help them out
they're at women's shelters are saying
it's it's mutual yeah it becomes mutual
and this is the thing again I haven't
experienced that myself so I'm saying
I'm so sorry I'm just gonna finish so be
like I'm saying it's like this is a way
that men are discriminated against if a
woman's abused there are women's
shelters everywhere there are no men's
shelters and there's all these little
things in society that once you see it
you can't unsee it where I I genuinely
believe that men are the most
discriminated against group in society
in terms of emotionally I do agree with
that just because I do think there's not
really much safe space for a lot of men
to talk about how they felt like there
was a video that went viral of Ruger it
was performing at a show and a woman
grabbed his private parts he was so like
upset by it like he couldn't perform
like he just dropped the mic and just
walked off and nothing would have
happened to that woman like to me that
is so unfair that he would probably just
think oh you know what that's a show but
he got violated
there's not a space for men to talk
about how they feel and actually what
they go through as well because we hear
about women a lot but not men so I do
agree with that in that sense but even
even and I talk about this like like a
lot of times women were just like bailed
out of bad decisions we make and it's
like if if we're if you're bad with
money and you get homeless you have a
women's shelter men are just homeless I
went there's a homeless shelter down the
street I want to do an interview there
like 90 of the homeless people there are
men but it's like nobody cares unless
it's a woman you know there was um
I can't remember it was somewhere in the
Middle East there was a group of women
that were like kidnapped and it was like
National headlines or whatever there was
a group of men that were kidnapped and
slaughtered and they didn't even talk
about it's like they only care when it's
women it's like once you and when I
first heard this stuff I was like no but
then once you see it it's like you can't
unsee it no but men are I think that I
understand what you're saying but
because men have so much power in
society if a man is homeless it'll be
like you have so much power like what
percent of what percent of men have
power that's like me saying that's like
me saying Okay
um
like when they when they say oh you can
get flown out to Dubai and all this
stuff and I'm like
a lot of girls I'm like I've never been
offered anything like I haven't been
offered [ __ ] like like and it's an even
smaller percent it's like two one
percent of men that really like the
whole place so right because women have
to take maternity leave already they are
already but you have the choice you can
choose but you can remember you can't
you could choose to be a boss you could
choose not to have kids and under 30 a
lot of women are out earning men in
cities so what do you say to that well
is it wouldn't want to have kids though
so which is that's what I'm trying to
say in society Society so like favors
men really so it's how it's a bit unfair
to just say how do how does Okay can I
can I have an example how how does
society favor men well like the high
paying jobs I know you're gonna say
women don't want to do the the high
paying jobs but most of the high paying
jobs they favor men like a woman has to
work let me let me ask you a few
questions those roles let me let me ask
you a question
um the NBA
it's it's mostly it's mostly I it's like
what 60 70 black roughly do they
discriminate against Asians there's like
no Asians in the NBA oh no but then also
you're saying that better no no no no no
no no I'm saying does the NBA
discriminate against Asians there are
very few Asians in the NBA what I'm
saying is in any group you you're never
going to find true equality when of
outcome because different groups like
different things so I think Asians make
up like 90 something percent of like I
don't there's they're like typically in
the U.S sorry please don't come at me
for stereotypes but but they they make
up a higher percentage of like like
higher education admissions yeah so
you're never going to have true equality
and it's like me personally so but I'm
saying that I'm saying we shouldn't I
don't care about men no I'm saying we
should have to say no I'm saying we
shouldn't fight for True equality
because people want to do different
things in different groups and I'm
saying in the top one percent I've seen
what it takes to get there I've seen
firsthand I've seen my dad I grow up he
he worked 60 70 hours a week he didn't
have a life he didn't have friends most
women Valley like we value a social life
we value having fun like what I've had
to do the last three years to build this
like Jess most girls would not do it oh
no not at all oh no and it's like it's
like and that's okay but that doesn't
mean women are being discriminated
against it means they don't want to work
60 70 hours a week I interviewed top
like
um I decided I wanted more rich friends
when I lived in Milwaukee and I just
asked Executives if I could like a
billion dollar companies if I could sit
there have a coffee with them and just
interview them about their life and both
of them are that I got to interview I
could see the one deficit they had in
their life neither of them really had
families and it was really sad and you
can tell both of them like missed out on
a part of life and you could tell they
regretted it you can't have everything
and women don't want to do those roles
because they are
ungodly hard can you imagine having like
some women do you're you're better I
said I said I think like in the 90s
women couldn't even vote this is in the
90s the 90s so yeah it was like 1918. no
that's not women got the right to vote
20s no it was 1918. you said 18 18 oh
18.
okay
women couldn't even so remember but why
why didn't women have the right to vote
women so historically men had to go to
war and fight that is why women couldn't
vote was because we if you had the
choice today in 2022 when we were in war
and you had to go fight on the front
lines would you pick it I personally and
this is where people take me out of
context and say I don't think women
should vote personally if I in 2022 had
the choice where I had to go fight in
the front lines just like the men in a
war or I could give up my right to vote
I would give up my right to vote and
that's what happened back then is they
equated voting with going to war because
all I'm trying to put is but I agree
with that because yeah men do take a lot
on themselves the fact that they fight
for us I I appreciate that but the stuff
that they do but I couldn't but I'm
saying I'm saying we weren't
discriminated against it was just how
Society ran we weren't discriminated
against we had a freedom like that was a
freedom that came with the
responsibility of getting drafted that
wasn't discrimination if you wanted to
be equally drafted go vote yeah but what
I'm trying to say is that's how who's
picking that who's anyone anyone yeah
she's like I would give it up that's
what a point yeah because they talked
about politics and it's also the same
thing women didn't have access to
education
they couldn't own property which means
that realistically it was you you could
typically remember back then it was
typical for people to get married young
so it was typical for them so so the the
reason was when you were married it was
you were looked at as one and that was
and typically women submitted to their
husbands and trusted their husbands with
their judgment women like tip so that's
why the property like the property thing
happened and same with the property it
was like like women still could own
properties if they did not get married
um but you know but typically then women
got married
if we want to go back into history I'll
tell you something about history that I
think and this is why shout out Emily I
mentioned that's why I mentioned to
um Andrew Tate that my problem wasn't
necessary with men it is with the men
that are running the machine that
obviously controls our societies because
when women first started going to work
they started going to work out of the
fact that there was a lack of men in the
country because there was war going on
war wars so women had to pick up go to
work and do their thing cool from the
aftermath of War there's women that
already in the workplace and then
there's women that also left widowed
which means that they now have a choice
either you stuff at home with your
family and become out and stay a
housewife or you're gonna get up and
you're gonna go to work and that's how a
lot of women have become what they call
masculine because they come out of a
trauma they come out also the
consequences of history and this is why
at this point and what I've been trying
to say for time is let's stop trying to
blame women for what's going on in
society right now let's understand that
this is a construct and a consequence of
history and last let's start respecting
me because we cannot go back and and I I
agree with you I'm not I'm not saying
it's one gender or the other I'm just
saying like we have been talking about
the man forever
it's like we like they I don't want no
scrub scrubs
like there's there's no there's no
there's no song saying I don't want no
whale a whale like nobody's saying that
no and I'm saying like we they have had
like we have had decades where we
started it's like now the men are
finally talking and we can't even give
them their fed that's kind of true
because even men when they're singing
about women they sang a lot about love
songs it was nice
I feel like from the moment you're born
I don't know if it's just in an African
home in an African home you're literally
race to cater for your man from that's
good I was eight so he's like you need
to know how you work for your mouth you
need to know look you should for your
man you should be thankful you were
naturally taught game a lot of girls
didn't get taught that they didn't get
that yeah like a lot of a lot of women
would love like eat I mean my parents
just started my parents my parents
started dating when they were 17. my mom
taught me no game she's like meet your
husband in high school a lot of women
aren't taught the basic necessities of
being a woman like cooking shocking to
me yeah well it's a privilege like you
you have something in your holster in
your bag that you can whip out whenever
you need to for a man like okay I can
cook for him I can clean for him because
you have it on you a lot of women had to
learn that on their on their own or just
had to go throughout life and learning
it they they never taught it or they
never needed to have it until they were
in a position where like oh I I can't do
this on my own I can't cook I can't
clean I can't work a simple vacuum I
can't do this because things have been
done for me my whole life or I was never
taught that and so you shouldn't look at
it as it like oh I was taught this from
jump I was taught how to cater to my man
or be a woman you should take them and
like African women or like women like me
Nigerian background especially that's
all we know it's about even like now I'm
26 my mom tells me if I'm 30 without a
husband I'm basically used okay okay but
you you at least so so if you look at
dating app data she's right
she's absolutely right so so so if you
look at dating app data that's when the
the numbers change where like women
typically have more like Leverage on
dating apps than than men until 30 and
then men typically do I I can't remember
if some girl was going over the study
but but and so like she was being honest
and if anything you should be thankful
for how well they prepped you for the
world because a lot of girls
hit 30 and have no idea not like this is
a privilege a lot of girls don't have a
dad or a mom to like tell them these
things and even me like my mom didn't
know [ __ ] about dating or the dating
landscape and yeah and it's like so you
at least know this at 26 where you can
still make choices that that would get
you in a better position at 30 where
other girls are gonna hit 30 completely
blind and screwed oh but you know what I
although today I'm not in your side I
will agree with that and the only thing
I will do is say slightly different I
will say like for example for me like I
mentioned my dad passed away when I was
12. but I grew up seeing my mom cater to
my dad so I learned a lot from him but
then after he was gone what my mom did
is teach me these survival skills that
you need anyways to be able to make it
through the world so I believe that even
things like cooking so when this is that
that's all type of kind of like
self-care and once you learn to take
care of yourself you'll be able to learn
to take care of someone else but the
fact that a lot of the time a lot of
women don't still have the ability to
take accountability means you're not
taking care of yourself because you
don't even know what you're doing wrong
so you can't even be better so when you
go into a relationship you land yourself
in trouble that's what it is what you
should be able to do for yourself or you
can do for others if not then there's no
point in you trying to sell but you know
I'm a woman and why am I going to do
this for man do it for yourself how can
you not cook what's going to happen if
you can't cook what about the fact that
as a woman you're going to be the mother
and as I mentioned earlier as the mother
as the woman you're going to be more
nurturing so these basic life skills
forget about even for a man do it for
you and for the fact that one that you
may want to be a mother then everything
falls into place if that makes it an
easy appeal to swallow I do have a
question I agree with that I do have a
question
um from your perspective Brittany how
was it for you
um
correct me if I'm wrong you grew up with
just your mother
was raise my mom until about like nine
and then my grandma kind of took over so
when I was growing up I thought my mom
just didn't want to be around but my
grandma was really controlling it was
basically like I'm the mom now so like
she kicked my mom out and my grandma was
my caretaker my grandma and grandpa so I
was right so my grandparents the uh half
the other half of my life okay how how
was that for you in terms of just
learning how to be a woman whenever you
reach that point I felt like a lot of
their ideas were just really outdated I
felt like they were really strict and it
was smothering so even just going to a
simple party or going to a friend's
house
like as an adult do I see why maybe
parents aren't so quick to let you go
over to someone's house yes but it was
to a place where you couldn't even
Explore
um I didn't really learn too much from
my grandma about being a wife or
um how to be in a relationship because I
always felt like they just tolerated
each other I never really saw
the love like the bond
um I've never really seen that it's just
always something I've known to be true
but I've never seen anybody do it yeah
so I felt like my grandma was trying to
get me to cook and do little stuff like
that but it just was never something and
I like I really took an interest in I'm
like I I genuinely never felt like I
belonged in the kitchen like and that's
where two
I resented how like my thought process a
lot growing up because I'm like why
can't I just be a little bit more simple
a little bit more obedient maybe a more
agreeable not have such a strong opinion
not be so introspective
um that's just where I'm just different
so I feel like my grandma tried to teach
me how to cook but as far as catering to
a man no I learned everything on the Fly
and that's where I think sometimes maybe
I get a little frustrated with the
internet's perspective because I'm like
you don't even know what I had to go
through to even be able to speak with
this awareness like I've had to bump my
head so many times to just be able to
sit and sit in my car and tell you give
you a sermon you know so I just never
felt like I really was prepared to be a
wife ever genuinely and you're not alone
I think a lot of girls feel like that
like I mean how many I don't think the
stuff that we talk about on these
podcasts would be so shocking if women
weren't lied to for 50 years yeah and I
think it's like even talking to Andrew
today like wasn't it helpful like when
he was talking about stuff I was even me
and I listened to this stuff all the
time I was like oh I never thought of
that like you're just talking about how
to get a guy to stop playing video games
I was like I wish I knew this
I was like wow yeah that's actually a
good one when I think about it do you
want to try it do you think that coming
from
a two-parent home and it's like a loving
environment it's for everybody that it
sets you up more for success to be able
to operate in relationships or be
willing to submit to whoever the man is
because you've seen it growing upwards
as it just does it not have an effect I
I think that's a really great question I
know a lot of people who grew up in dual
parent households and they saw their
mother getting cheated on and staying
and I like I know like someone recently
they were married for like 25 years or
so or 23 years and she left basically
when the kids were old enough to just
like none of them were in high school
anymore
um and I I remember when I was talking
to her she felt like she was setting her
kids up for Success because we're all
under the same roof
um they have a better chance of whatever
right and it still was damaging because
you are witnessing your mother tolerate
disrespect for uh security how did the
kids know
how the kids how the kids know what that
she was being cheated on
it was something that
this particular situation it was I know
one instance was like one of their
family friends oh [ __ ] yeah it was
really close to home stuff and there was
another another scenario where it was it
was one of the family friends they were
cheating on or is that told them
um no it was they were cheating with one
of their family friends so like someone
like let me go over to her house all the
time so my dad is sleeping with her oh
so he they would see the parent cheat it
I'm not exactly I don't I don't think it
was they physically saw it but it was
something that the mom would share
um that they would hear arguments too
like if they weren't even if they
weren't involved in the actual argument
they would overhear
um which obviously you know showing
exposing your kids to that stuff is one
thing but the other instance was
um the dad was going out to the club
with like the sun and he had a girl with
them so it's like that direct like I
don't respect your mom in this way I can
do what I want to do and your mom's
still going to stay so that's where I
feel like it really depends on what's
going on in that household because
seeing your mom be basically
disrespected for
comfort
it's like it sends the wrong message
about love I agree like blatant dislike
I can't believe he brought his son to a
club and [ __ ] like that that's crazy
yeah like the girl with him but I just
think sometimes you know we never talk
about like the women's part to play in
this and like one one in four marriages
are sexless
one is four and so I just think if
you're gonna starve a man and he's
begging you to sleep with him and
someone comes on a platter like that's
why I say we never talk about why the
men cheat and a lot of people will take
this out of context like I believe in
cheating but like there are times where
the woman is not sleeping with the man
and then he cheats but he's not
naturally inclined to
and and that's a conversation we don't
really have I'm not saying it's okay but
it's almost like what did you what did
you expect but at the same time too like
again like let's just like I said make
it with me and you like if you're my
girlfriend and you don't want to sleep
with me the the my first go-to isn't to
go try to sleep with someone else I'm
not getting it from you I would want to
explore the emotional depths of whatever
you're feeling what am I not doing why
do you not want to promote me I want to
be intimate with you but you're thinking
like a woman and that that's how a woman
right right but like like men it's just
come out you know how guys are like I'm
sure you you especially like like like
being as beautiful as you are like most
guys if you put yourself on a platter in
front of them would be down yeah I mean
yeah yeah that's saying much but yeah
yeah I mean but that's that's what I'm
saying like men men have you're giving
him sex he'll still cheat because
there's options I I would say most men
that have women on them on a silver them
on a silver platter will cheat yeah like
I would say but not all men most most
men work a normal nine to five they go
to work they come home there's maybe one
or couple girls in the office whatever
that he might cheat there but most men
girls aren't really checking for so if
you date an average guy unless you're
starving him of sex it's a lot of work
for men to go out and get sex that's why
I say what part did you have to play in
him cheating like okay if you you were
with a elite athlete right
they're just gonna cheat that's just I
see the normal I saw D3 basketball
players
[Laughter]
but okay but like your average nine to
five Joe it it's a bunch of work for him
to go out and get a girl so it's like
what part did you have to play a lot of
women are always nagging on their
husbands they got they gained a bunch of
weight after they had a kid Brittany
showing us first hand you don't have to
do that and and it's like then they stop
sleeping with him and the men are like
wait wait wait wait I thought I got a
120 pound wife that was good to sleep
with me all the time now she got the
ring where I'm locked into a contract
for life and you could take my kids with
me and my money and put me on child
support all the stuff and now you're
gonna gain a bunch of weight and not
sleep with me wig what did you expect to
happen you're not holding up your yeah
and so men like that's another reason
men don't want to get married because
they're like oh I had a guy tell me this
he's like I don't want to get married I
don't want her to get fat but you know
why this is why a lot of the time is all
amazing just say one thing
a lot of the time the reason why some
some men get a little bit messed up
comes down to
insecurities and let me land and I'll
explain to you why a lot of the time the
women that let themselves go in a
relationship or in a marriage is also
down to the fact that men now that they
own the woman they do not want the woman
to be approached they don't want the
woman to be desired by other men it
comes down to the whole territorial
thing which then means that you are now
going to punish or going to complain are
you going to put a woman in a position
where she feels like whatever she looks
like is a problem so she'll let go of it
and she won't even work for it that's
also another thing another side of
things women don't just let go of
themselves for no reason they start to
let go of themselves because there's no
desirability in general many to
understand as a woman for you to be
beautiful and to feel beautiful it's not
just about you telling me that I'm the
most beautiful girl in the world you
know I just to me it was just nonsense
girls let themselves go because they eat
too much and they're lazy I know a
couple girls that got married and gained
like 50 pounds none of them are happy
they gain the weight they always wish
they were thinner but they're too lazy
to fix it
it's like I don't know and now they have
the ring it's like less incentive you
know when you get you guys know when you
get break up with someone you are in the
gym you were trying to look like you're
not me too me too I'm not saying I'm
special me too or in the gym we're
trying to like get our bodies right all
this stuff and then we get a man and we
don't we don't keep it I mean the way I
was raised you catered to your man say
you've got this is your king and I'm not
I'm not saying you you need to look good
friends so I don't know about letting
yourself go uh no I I got him now I need
to keep him I I agree with you but I'm
not saying you in particular I'm saying
this is what the men are saying this is
these are the issues they're saying yeah
obviously I I think it's wrong like when
you get into a relationship I don't
think like letting yourself go I think
it's a problem as a woman like why
should you do that because it's Gonna
Leave You you think so I do agree do you
think a man can leave a woman if she
lets herself go he's asked her multiple
times to lose the weight and she won't
do it
I wouldn't say assuming let's say
there's no kids involved because kids
kind of change things well let's say
there's no kids well to be honest yes
because no but it's not unfair you'll be
telling your guy how many times do you
say listen I told him a million times to
not this do not do this I told him a
million times to get up off his ass I
told him a million times to do this yeah
he didn't do it I left him if you as a
man you're speaking to you to your girl
and you're trying to make sure that she
improves and she is better and she's not
doing that the problem is not that she's
not losing the weight the problem is the
mentality which is the fact that you are
not willing to be better and get better
so that we can both be happy and have
the Sun for Life see this is what this
is this is what this is what I mean when
I say it's like there's little things
that are open missandry against men and
we don't always realize it so like in
this instant you kind of hesitated but
if I came forward and I'm not saying I
don't think it's intentional but if I
said yeah I left him because he wouldn't
work he wouldn't get a job you would be
like yes girl like and you know yeah you
and you know you would you shouldn't be
with a bum and it's like that's a female
bum a 300 pound whale I'll say it I'll
say it again be careful be careful the
reason I'm a bit more sensitive towards
women is because I obviously you guys
are saying your reality is different but
my reality it's always been you've got
to be better for your man so my world
has always been about the men and and
I'm like so what is it doing for me so
yeah I've got to learn to cook clean do
all this stuff take care of my man but
how is he helping me emotionally how is
he helping me feel good but man that's
not their job to help you emotionally
that's like we're I think that's no okay
okay
yeah but like they don't want to they
don't they don't they don't want to hear
so this is this is doing all this for
what what am I like okay you can't I'm
not saying they should never like talk
to you or what like ignore you all the
time but I'm just saying like like
typically historically you wouldn't even
see your husband that much that's not
their job you vent to your friends like
your relationships with men and this is
something I learned like one time okay I
had an ex-boyfriend and I was talking I
was like this person and he was just
like shh I don't care
and at first I was like
what do you mean you don't care like I
was like that was so rude but I like sat
and thought about it and I'm like you
know I'm like dumping my problems onto
him and that's not his job he's not my
therapist like we don't want a guy
that's dumping all his problems on to us
we're okay we're okay being a companion
right but I'm saying I'm saying so again
again like they remember this is things
that we look for from men but men don't
look for from us and so and that's
that's doing all this for you what are
you doing for me typically what I'm
saying I don't want I don't want to be
cooking for my man I'll tell you I'll
tell you so that's what they look so but
I'm saying like the you're always gonna
get protection and that's the one thing
like so okay okay okay okay okay but if
the world but if the world
living living here living here I I wish
I had a boyfriend because it it scares
me a lot of times like living like just
you know like people know where the
studio is sometimes right and there are
crazy people and I'm like it would be so
nice if I had a guy here just like not
even just to like if he was staying here
and it would be like like if something
happened I know he would like there's
some level of comfort you have with just
having a man next to you and knowing
that if [ __ ] goes south you don't have
to call the police that he's going to
protect you like you know they say women
prefer fat guys with muscles over skinny
men yeah because because it's like Ellie
I ever thought I agree that's I would
take that too not sure and you know why
why for example for me I love to cook
for people and one of the things that I
love the most as well is to cook for my
man and I'll tell you why because at the
end of the day whether know I'm a bad
girl and I'm you know successful and I
can do my own [ __ ] and I don't need the
man it feels nice to me to show somebody
you know love through food love through
things that you are actually much better
at doing obviously I would don't mind if
a man can cook for me great if you can
cook for himself great but I like to
cook why because then when I go out
he'll pay for Me Maybe or he'll fulfill
a certain role of chivalry that today in
today's age is not needed but because I
fulfilled my role of chivalry as a woman
he'll give me that because we can't say
oh he needs to pay a guy that don't pay
on the first day a guy don't don't do
this all of these things okay there's
there's a transaction with that which
means you also cater to him if a woman
if a woman don't cook on the second date
then she then she ain't wifey we've
never heard that that's what I'm saying
it's like the the double but I think it
depends on what you want in a man like
you saying you want a man that will
um help you financially but I don't to
me that's not a priority okay because
what I want is that's a father someone
that would be a good father to my kids
is gonna be there I need time I need you
to okay
would you prefer if all would you okay
prefer let's talk about prefer if you
could would you want a guy that made
more money than you if all things okay
okay okay okay
wait wait wait okay if you could would
you prefer a man that's stronger than
you yes or no yes okay okay if you could
would you prefer a man that's smarter
than you maybe can fix things around the
house yes no okay so that's what I'm
saying there are other things that men
bring
that you get just from having a man
around outside of money like I love that
I can call my like we all know as women
and maybe maybe you guys are better than
me my my air pressure light is always on
my oil has never changed my my smoke
alarm battery will always be beeping and
am I it's like when the men come around
and they're like how are you living like
this like my dad'll like run around
you're smiling I bet you can think of a
time where someone's done this right and
they run around and they'll just fix
everything and just be like why are you
doing this and it's just something like
comforting like I I feel better like if
I'm stressed or whatever I just love
talking to my dad and my brothers like
there's just something about talking to
like masculine men where it's like you
just feel better
for a man to be masculine of course but
what I'm saying is I value more in a man
I want a partner I like I don't care
about all this fixed and light bulb we
can get someone to do that I need
someone that cares about me after I've
had a long day off I would be really
curious I want to talk to you
such a long day I want you to just
listen to me when women talk to men
they're like okay you're telling me all
this stuff what's the solution they want
to know how are you going to fix
whatever it is you're telling me that
was the solution well at least you've
been a companion no no they're they want
you they they really don't care about
the venting is mental they're like okay
you've told me all this stuff but you're
not gonna fix it don't come back to me
and say the same stuff that you told me
the day before fix it and move on that's
that's how men's will come up with a
solution together
that's how it's work and maybe because I
can't watch the question questions
that's why I know that many yeah your
last relationship how long was it uh
probably like oh I don't like to get
personal I like nearly uh okay okay I
was just gonna say longer than six
months yeah yeah okay okay did you end
it or did he
I ended it okay so so this is just from
the men's point of view okay women will
say I want an emotionally available man
and this isn't just you remember I see
you in different bodies every day and
and it's like so then like what they'll
do is they'll realize that the same man
they said were emotionally available I
dated him we also ended it with yes and
and so and I've asked this question a
lot it's very rare it was the other way
around typically when I ask this like oh
he was emotionally available I got the
things I wanted it's like well why did
it and usually she ended it but I'm not
gonna because I I versus you don't you
don't have to you don't have to say why
I don't have to say one I won't go into
it I respect all my exes I think they
were amazing I've dated very good men I
respect them they were Kings right but
the reason I wouldn't even say like the
full reason but in terms of just the
reason a lot of women leave a
relationship is because they didn't have
other things that keep them excited so
things like being ambitious for example
or a man that is confident in himself a
man that wants more for himself in life
those are the stuff that sometimes if
it's missing or maybe a man that doesn't
take care of himself like yeah you could
be emotionally available to me I love
that and that's the reason I stayed with
you but I need you to also work on
yourself did you not you know be a
better man and if you don't want that
for yourself it's a bit harder if you're
not did you not ask them these questions
or know this stuff before you got into a
relationship I'm not going to talk about
my relationship
I just want to like this this is simple
yes and I don't want to like go deep
into it were you like did you have those
I think you never really know someone
until you're in a relationship I think
it takes a lot of time to know the type
of person it is because when you get
into a relationship you see the good
stuff because things I've always
prioritized is I want a great family
like I do not want to be a single mother
so I will always pick um I don't care
about how much money you I don't care
about protector I need a man that's
going to be a good father to my children
and usually those are men that are good
communicating so so this is this is I'm
just gonna tell you what remember what
you said this is contradicting what you
said because if you don't care about
money then you don't care if he's
ambitious
and that's if you don't remember earlier
you were talking about how you didn't
care so much about money you care more
about emotionally and I don't care about
him paying for me because but I'm saying
then so so if you're ambitious if you're
ambitious
okay okay okay but I know so that
translates into money in the future
right so okay okay so this is where
right right okay but this is why men
don't really trust what women say
because you're saying oh I don't care
about the money but when you when you're
presented with a man who's like eh I'm
good with the money I have and I'm not
that ambitious you're like no I can't
stay for this if it came across that I
said I don't care about men that likes
as money I I care about a man that's
ambitious right you don't have to have
so you would not but you need to be hard
working I'm wanting money when I say I
don't care about money it means a little
more I'm not gonna go for a man purely
because of money because it's a hard
work and I'm ambitious so I'm not gonna
put that on you to pay for my lifestyle
because I want to prioritize other
characteristics in a man but to say that
I don't care about money yes I do I do
because I I Love Money myself I gotta
make money so my man's gonna make money
but I'm just saying this is why men like
don't believe what women say because we
constantly contradict ourselves and it's
like the other question I'm just telling
you how the men would hear what you said
if you said oh they're great guys
um but they were bums they would either
hear that you you date losers or they
would hear that you're not loyal because
you leave good men this is just I'm
telling you how they would take it
[Music]
I think like my biggest problem is like
I first of all I hear all of you like I
totally agree with what a lot of you
guys are saying I think my biggest
problem is that I do want someone that I
can talk about my day with and what you
said is a fact men are problem solvers
they don't want to hear you gripe they
just want to fix it and that's where
I'm going through this like trying to
figure out what exactly I'm wanting or
needing but like I want someone that can
listen to that yeah and I don't know if
I'm asking for a [ __ ] unicorn yeah
but I want to be able to
be able to talk about what happened at
the nail salon I do want to have that
friendship I don't need you every single
time I talk about something to try to
fix it right of course we want someone
who can who has the potential to fix a
light bulb whatever great but I think
that was the big that's been the biggest
Factor I've been missing in my
relationships is like a friend and so
that's where I don't know how it's
supposed to go how it's going to end
what it's supposed to be how how am I
supposed to adjust my expectations what
am I am I asking for something that's
unrealistic I do have a question
um
could you think
of a friend that you have right now that
you could potentially see yourself with
I'm gonna be very honest with you I do
not really buy into the whole male
friend thing that's just a
probably a bit of a jaded belief I can
probably I can be aware enough to say
that
um
I don't know I I honestly was sexually
assaulted by my best friend before my
30th birthday actually so I have a
little bit of a like I'm I don't want to
close that part of my heart off but I
just
any doubt I had about it it felt like it
was confirmed a little bit I'm like if
if you if I'm drunk and you're given the
chance you're gonna finger me in my
sleep and that's like literally what
happened to me so so yeah so it's like I
just I don't know if I buy into that
just yet but never say never but you
know what can I just say something that
is quite interesting yeah
I grew up having mostly guy friends
because I was a tomboy I played Sports
is everything I used to be with boys
that is why even though I have a more
feminine image now what's inside is
quite different and one thing that I
understand very well and one thing that
they told me and one thing that I've
picked up along the years
what happened in the nail salon a lot of
the time is petty and I'm not trying to
say this because I'm trying to be Richie
because I know and I have girlfriends
and when they come to me to talk about
what happened in the nail salon I'm like
wow how is this going to add to my life
this is mental clutter do you know that
I have this to do tomorrow I have this
to do tomorrow I have big things to
worry about you're trying to chew my ear
off over something that is so petty that
if you took two seconds to think within
yourself and reflect you'll be able to
let it go straight away and then instead
of spending 5-10 minutes talking about
something pointless we could be talking
about something that is more productive
and sometimes more substantial and I
think that a lot of the time what we
girls get get you know and I say wiggles
just so that I don't single myself out
but what girls tend to do a lot of the
time is waste time talking about
nonsense that doesn't mean anything I
don't care about what happened to the
nail salon what's that doing to advance
my life you can say you know what these
people in the nail salon was so damn
rude you know babe I need to go to the
next one I need to go somewhere else
actually do you know what next time what
do you reckon I should say I that's a
great way to get him involved but even
still there's no point I think the the
point is like relationships work better
if as women we can unload our problem
and talk to other women about our
problems and go to our men about like
problems we want to solve it's not to
say you can never talk to like of course
my mom would [ __ ] to my dad about Tracy
[ __ ] you Tracy
but but it's just saying like in general
men don't want to hear about it and it's
like if you're selling we're the cars
right and I know women aren't cars but
like we're the cars you have to know
your buyer and if your buyer doesn't
like listening to our problems maybe we
could try to tell tell them about them
less unless we want them fixed yeah and
don't put and don't put like a lot of
the emotional because this is the thing
girls sometimes can be really Petty and
it's like I understand because I'm
always on the guy's side with this
because I don't have time for that I
also say to some of my girls like listen
you're really stressing me out because
we've gone over the same problem I've
given you the same solution we're still
talking about it those things are not
needed you can have some you can be your
best a best friend with your with your
man so easy you can talk about a million
different things where you expand each
other's minds I think that sometimes
what goes wrong is that we think our
friend has to be somebody that is
burdened with our mental clutter that's
what it is because I've I have amazing
conversations with men and even in
previous relationships I've always been
able to sustain a conversation why
because I don't talk about things that I
perceive to be just like okay like here
we go just talking for the sake of it
obviously if the ghost is Juicy then
yeah and you gotta tell them you know
what I'm saying make it interesting make
it a package make it be something where
they can be involved in whereas a lot of
the time we're just like and this
happened and this happened we just want
to tell a story and not actually even
have the input from someone else and
that's really and I I definitely agree
with that for sure without a doubt I
think that's where when we were talking
about the concert stuff right like if I
if I'm telling you don't go I have a
feeling whatever the reason don't go but
we're saying that we want to have
genuine good solid friendships with
women so again so taking some of that
responsibility off our man confiding in
women that we know would would maybe
care about the nail salon stuff but then
it's like
I don't know I guess for me it's like so
then if my friend wants to go out to a
concert I have to kind of like consider
actually consider not going but the
emotional part that I don't get from you
I get from her so I still have to have
in my mind autonomy like I should still
be able to
challenge
going to the concert because this
relationship helps our relationship stay
afloat would you prefer would you prefer
a guy that you could trust his judgment
like have you can you think of a man
like in your life at all that you like
genuinely if he told you not to do
something you would do it just because
you respect him so much
one person maybe
um so it's like that type of respect
like I'll give you an example my my dad
um I respect him so much I do my
accounting and I want to hire an
accountant so bad and I like it just
look at her she knows how much I hate it
I [ __ ] about it I [ __ ] about it to
everyone I'm sorry guys I'll keep
bitching and I literally because my dad
says you need to know your numbers you
need to do this like I just do it
because he says and I I don't want to do
it and it's like that's the level of
respect men want to have from us it's
like so much that even when you disagree
even when you don't want to do it you
just do it because you love them and you
respect them and it's someone that you
trust so much you know that they would
never like abuse you yeah like that's
that's the type of like relationship we
aspire to have yeah it's like it because
it has to be someone you trust yeah I
feel like I have just never had that so
I think that's where the con the concert
talk can get triggering because you're
like well what the [ __ ] like if I can't
talk to you about the nail salon I'm
gonna go hang on my friends I still need
to have a life I can't completely trust
in your judge because I can't completely
trust you like yeah I
do not have a man in my life or really
ever really had when I said maybe to one
but even then
um so if it's not a [ __ ] yes of the [ __ ]
no right so it's like I've never had a
guy where I feel like yeah if he says
don't go I'm not going so and so and
that's what is where I'm working on
myself to where I can manifest someone
like that because
clearly like there there's something
inside of me that's attracting these
type of men to where it's like I need to
correct something in here well and it's
making the men of the future pay for the
mistakes of your past yeah and so it's
like it's not his fault that you grew up
how you grew up it's not his fault like
who you've dated before yeah and it's
like we always hate when a guy comes in
and we date him and he's like you're
cheating on me you know what I'm saying
like he's all up in our phone and like
all this stuff and you're like
we can think of someone but we do it to
men all the time where it's like we
can't submit because we're thinking oh
we might do what that guy did or that
guy did where it's like a good like a
good if a good solid man came in like
someone who loved you respected you and
wanted what was best for you said
something you're going to be questioning
him and it's gonna throw like it's gonna
drive him off yeah and with that said
though I'm not gonna lie I Look to have
um the man that I want for my future is
a man that can Inspire and teach me
that's why you want a unicorn I've
talked I want a unicorn because I Am a
Unicorn as a woman what can I say but I
do want a man that when I say baby why
can't I go though
and he'll be like look what if he said
just trust me
I would do that even just trust me babe
just trust me I would like you sure cool
then I'll trust you it's just a
reassurance just how women have
intuition men men have intuitions that
we can't understand just how they can't
understand our intuition but with
something you said earlier the novel
about how you like to cook for people
because it's just something you love to
do and you love to have that experience
with them and it made me think about
what Andrew Tate was saying earlier
about how when a man is able to I can't
remember exactly what he said but did he
use the word inspire or he uses some
word but when a man is able to be that
to a woman that is like you cooking for
your man it's like that that feeling
that you get like oh it's like a sense
of just like oh yeah like I love doing
that for you and that's how men are they
want to be able to be in that space
where it's like only a man can be and be
able to do that because they love doing
that and that's just innate in them yeah
do you know what I think though is a bit
of a problem
I mean well like I've said I've had good
exes they've been good communicators but
then you guys say oh if a man's
ambitious he's got this whatever going
on he doesn't have time to listen to you
I think that's not right because like I
said I've had exes that want to
communicate with me so it's like it is
possible because they are men you said
remember remember I listened to your
words yeah and you said your ex has
lacked ambition bums love to listen
moms are great communicators well Market
okay okay low ambition men my point they
love to listen
they're very impossible the reason these
I value men feel like they don't need to
be good communicators is because we
women are letting them accept it we're
accepting that it's okay for you yeah
but you're communicating you're trying
to because you're going to demand you're
going to men and saying why aren't you
perfect like that that's essentially
what you do like you want you want
perfect that's okay okay okay again
again again okay look it look it okay
okay so my my dad again I I've grown up
I know these men okay not not not the
entertainers the athlete them I do not
know but but the businessman right like
the one percent like businessman I grew
up around them they work 60 70 hours a
week do you want to come home from
working 12 hours a day now you walk
through the door babe do you Boo this is
what happened to me this is what
happened to that that and that and then
did it also I have this problem with you
also why can't you and then he's like
why are you not listening to me babe so
it's like he's he's working his ass off
all day trying to provide for you and
now on top of that he has to be your
therapist and now you might not look at
it as therapy but this is how the men
see it but I've had men I have had rich
men that do have time it's just okay
which you know I didn't like though but
okay what what is what did they what did
they do okay what wait okay so what what
did you what did they do what what did
they do what do you mean what did they
do what was the what did the rich man do
oh they had business they had a business
you know yeah he had his thing going on
the point is I just didn't like him but
he community so again so again again
this goes this this again again this
this goes back to like watchful women
say not what they do because if I'm
hearing to you if he's rich and he's
emotionally available that sounds like a
golden ticket that sounds like unicorn
okay okay but but this is what this is
what but to me to me again so the men
would hear this and they would say well
she goes on dates with men that aren't
their types what's she doing to me like
this is this is how the men see it
they're gonna get to pick the men we won
no no you do you do so so if a man if a
man asks me on a date I have the option
to say yes or no so you do and I don't
want Anthony Joshua and I know it's
Anthony Joshua okay okay okay okay okay
my point is I'm telling you I'm just
telling you how the men will see it so
they hear this and they're now you're a
user you use men for their resources
because you're
you're a pretty girl you're 26. you're
not you're not 36 you're 26. yeah you
absolutely get to choose they're they're
but I'm not gonna do like that's one so
I don't care how good looking you are
okay I don't care I can't deal with
[ __ ] I can't do that okay but you
told me you say it Okay okay then die
okay okay then okay okay okay all right
look at me look at me look at me look at
me look at me look at me die alone
[Laughter]
and he said the money said I can't deal
with [ __ ] I can't deal with a woman
that's going to change my to chew my ear
off about these things usually and let
me tell you wait wait wait wait wait let
me tell you something and on top of that
as a high value woman I'm not gonna lie
as a high value woman you really hardly
have time to be discussing things that
are so futile if anything what you're
going to discuss with your man when you
come home from A Hard Day's work or
anything be like do you know what babe
I'm having this issue logistically I'm
trying to figure this out in my business
I'm trying to do this what the hell do I
do those are the sort of problems I
couldn't actually get a man involved in
those are the sort of things that as
women of today we kind of should concern
ourselves with a little bit more we are
no longer in high school I don't know
why we're having beef on a nail salon I
don't know why we always get ourselves
involved
it depends on the kind of friend that
you are to him who wants to have a
friend that is constantly draining you
with pointless uh issues I cut my
friends I cut girls off my friend group
because they drain my ears with nonsense
about nonsense and that is really
annoying and that's one of the things
that sometimes I say to girls and I say
to my friends I say to my friends around
me I say you are the reason why men hate
girls you are the reason why men will
cheat because they're there Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam and I say the main thing a
million times I'm like shut up like can
we talk about something better I'm just
I'm just gonna cause I know blessings so
I'm just gonna end with this I just
think we're sold a dream and I just
think a lot of the things we want and
just so you know I'm gonna people think
I never throw myself into this I think
at times there were things that I wanted
that probably were not realistic for
example you know at one point I wanted a
guy that was six seven
that's like half a percent of the
population is that realistic probably
not and I think the older we get the
more we see that things maybe are not
realistic and I just think a lot of the
things you're asking for if you want
them that's fine I don't knock you for
wanting what you want but I just think
they're not this man is not real
I am and and then and if he was and if
he and if he was and if he was if he was
real okay let's say he is real I will
find him I'll find him go ahead go
insert yeah let me know what it knows
and give him my number because I will
not argue
submissive I will make him feel like
he's not okay
until he says something you don't like
until he says you can't go here and
there he's a good man he also respects
me what if he tells you could never wear
Lashes in your life again you can never
get your nails done again that wouldn't
be my man my man has to respect me he
actually has to respect me okay
okay okay okay okay Esther look at me
look at me
die alone
[Applause]
okay okay
um I'd like a verbal confirmation that I
am not racist or sexist from you Esther
I didn't say you wanted
okay okay okay okay okay okay let's
let's let's I just this is all I need
done the pot am I racist
am I sexist
I think you've made comments that am I
do you think I'm a sexist person yes or
no I don't know yes or no yes or no the
stuff you said they're all quite sick
okay all right fine fine
um all right guys
anyways look at it this is gonna make
some good Clips anyways
um thanks guys for staying after hope
you enjoyed the pizza that's amazing
thank you for having us everyone say
thank you to blessing thank you blessing
the sweetest most quiet man I have ever
met you are probably a very good husband
I'll give you that
okay guys
um just so you know we have these convos
after podcasts all the time this one was
more heated you know with YouTube than
most of them are after shows okay
it's okay I don't like that this
representation is stronger okay okay
okay oh my God you guys see this is when
we say women are children this is right
here
anyways um
okay I don't believe you anyways um like
the video on your way out subscribe to
the channel